[Music]
i almost dropped out of school because
of money problems
my parents didn't work
and i had to sell tissues at traffic
lights
then i was taken to this foundation to
be helped so that i could go to school
again
children around the world had to earn
money and feed their families during the
pandemic
it's a worldwide phenomenon and it hit
indonesia especially hard
schools only reopened in early august
after 55 weeks
indonesia has the highest infection and
death rates in southeast asia and so the
risk of children being infected is also
very high
141 000 people have died from covert 19
more than 1 200 of them children
the very young are particularly affected
hunger and poverty are rising sharply
and babies have little resistance to the
aggressive delta variant
welcome to dw's covert 19 special i'm
daniel winter in berlin
kids are often ignored in discussions
about covert 19 because most of them are
less susceptible to serious symptoms
the recent study estimates over 8
million children around the world have
lost a parent or primary caregiver as if
that weren't bad enough those kids
suffer the knock-on effects of abuse or
mental health problems
as indonesia's covert death toll reached
over 140 000 this week the impact on
children there is particularly high
social workers have raised the alarm
seeing increasing numbers of orphaned
children in desperate need of care
what he misses most are the simple
things like going for a walk with his
dad
twelve-year-old dennis lost both of his
parents in the pandemic
today his uncle joins him to pay tribute
at the family grave
life has changed radically for the boy
from tongarang on the outskirts of
jakarta
he now lives with his older brother in
their parents home
muhammad is 19
and does what he can to hold on to some
form of normality
you'll know what it feels like to be a
parent
that was their last message
after saying that a few hours later
my parents died
the number of orphaned children in
indonesia is still rising even as the
pandemic in parts of the country slows
down the organization save the children
indonesia estimates that more than
eighteen thousand children have been
orphaned by coven 19 losing either one
or both parents
when the boys were vaccinated last month
the police in tangarang learned about
their recent loss
the police chief was especially moved
and has since personally given the boys
financial aid the father of six has even
offered to become a foster parent
[Music]
i'm a police officer by profession but
i'm also a human being with a heart that
is touched
i can't just stand by and watch because
i share the same destiny
when my parents died i'd entered junior
high school like dennis
parents took care of me so that i could
go to high school and become a police
officer
now it's my turn to give back
adoption process is still ongoing and
dennis hasn't made a final decision
where to live
but the boys are grateful for the
support
that is not tied up in red tape
without state benefits children in
poorer areas are often sent to
orphanages
as families don't have the financial
muscle to care for them
the problems these children face however
go beyond material issues
mental health plays a big role
and then there are legal challenges
some relatives also put money
to stop thousands of children from
slipping into poverty abuse and neglect
it will take the joint effort of
community members health care
professionals and relatives
mohammed is ready to do his part too to
help his brother cope with the grief and
to make sure that he one day gets into
university
and joining us now from east java
province's coveted 19 control task force
is makian gibral so we've seen there
some of the the devastating things that
kids have to go through but from your
perspective from what you've seen how
would you describe the situation for
kids in indonesia
yes daniel so basically today we have
4.1 million cases of coffee 90 where are
140 000 of them are dying due to coffee
19. for the children itself we have
uh between age 0 and 5 we have 121
000 cases or 2.9 percent and
for the age between 5 and 80 we have
four hundred and twenty four thousand so
basically ten point one percent so
around thirteen percent of coveted 19
cases in indonesia are from children
below 18.
so how much does poverty or
living conditions
affect the potential for children to be
harmed by covert 19 even indirectly
well basically it's interesting that our
children who are live in poor area are
living in the
village we have we which have low
literacy or coffee 19 they are more
prone to the infection because of you
know that their parents might not have
access to the
good health care information about
coffee 19 how to treat them as early as
possible so in the rural areas and the
poor area usually the cases of covet 19
from children are higher
and we've seen that according to the
indonesian pediatric society more than a
hundred indonesian children have died
every week since july have died from
covert 19. so why are children seemingly
so
susceptible to infections and deaths
there
yes i think it is interesting because
at the july indonesia face its second
wave uh the cases of the coffee 90s are
soaring high you know that
the hospital occupancy in only two weeks
at the june the hospital occupancy was
around 30 percent and then at the july
it's soaring high
up to 80 percent and the daily death of
coffee 19 cases was around 1 000 and 500
cases at that time we have delta florian
who have really massive spreading and
outplays and become the dominant
dominant mutation in indonesia and of
course with that rapid spread the number
of the
victims including from the children are
increasing rapidly however in the health
care facilities
usually hospitals in indonesia are more
prepared to fight with
adult or elderly cases of coffee 19 and
many hospitals are not really prepared
yet for the two children cases so at the
end of the day the the numbers of the uh
children who are dying because of lack
of facilities are are higher
all right so it's a serious issue there
um children being
hit hard by covert 19 but uh thank you
very much for joining us and explaining
us about it that's makian gibril thank
you very much
okay thank you very much
well now it's time for one of your
questions about covert 19 over to our
science science correspondent derek
williams
are the viruses related to sars cove ii
that cause sars and mers also airborne
pathogens
it took time and a whole lot of studies
before healthcare authorities were
certain enough to come out and state
clearly
that sars cov2 is primarily spread not
just via larger respiratory droplets
exhaled by infected people but also via
smaller aerosols
that's because the means by which a
pathogen is transmitted can be a really
complex thing to prove
especially when it infects others by
hanging suspended in the air
but
a lot of the evidence we have can't
really be explained any other way and
and studies have now made it the theory
that most experts agree on
when it comes to saris kobe 2 that
that it's transmitted from infected
people to others via droplets and
smaller aerosols
mostly indoors in poorly ventilated
rooms especially if those rooms are
crowded and people spend long periods of
time there
what we know about transmission in the
coronavirus that causes sars is a lot
more limited because only around eight
and a half thousand people have ever had
it and all of them were infected
almost 20 years ago but but experts
think it's more difficult to transmit
the cdc says
that the sars coronavirus spreads mostly
only through
larger respiratory droplets
during closer personal contact either
directly
or via surfaces contaminated by those
droplets
that
and another major factor that that
sufferers are mostly infectious only
when they have the full-blown symptoms
of the disease
that helped authorities get sars under
control
through strict quarantines
when it comes to mers
we know even less about transmission
than we do with sars because even fewer
people have contracted it which means
even fewer opportunities for study but
but it's believed that people can catch
it directly from animals and and camels
are a prime culprit a human to human
spread is also possible through close
contact but
as far as i can tell
no one has yet identified the exact
mechanisms of that spread